اسوا شيء قاعد يصير الان يطورون تشريع
وبعدين يطرح للقطاع للقطاع الخاص لي ابداء
الراي جاهز خالص
فالجوهر انصنع لما تطرحون انس الملاحظات
شكليه او كان تقول انت تعتبر خيانه ولا لا
خيانه الوطن
كان في همم
نظام التسمم الغذائي كان نظام مجحف حقيقي
احد المسؤولين قال لي
على اخر الزمن انه نسمح لتشريعات الدوله
تصنع في دهاليز القطاع الخاص
واحد في موضوع اخر في وزاره وزاره اخرى
يعني هذا تعتبر خيانه عظمى
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط الاذاعه الثمانيه وانا اعمل
جراسي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي وسولف معهم على المستجدات
والمستهدفات رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 ضيف حلقه
اليوم هو الامير وليد بن ناصر بن فرحان
مؤسس ورئيس شركه مكافاه الاستشارات همم من
زمان من يوم ما ابتدينا سقراط وموضوع
القطاع الخاص ما يعطي حقك توثيق للمرحله
الماضيه في ضيوف انقطاع الحكومي كانوا
يطرحون وجهه نظر او صوره معينه وفي ضيوف
في القطاع الخاص كانوا يطرحون وجهه نظر من
زاويتهم لكن ما حد في النص كده وقف وشرح
المشهد وشاف همم ايش اللي صار ولك خص لنا
اياه لذلك كانت حلقه همم منتظره مع ابو
سلطان لانه هو يقف في المنتصف تقريبا
ويقدم استشارات للطرفين في نموذج عمل جديد
وبالنسبه لي مثير اللي هي شركه مكافاه في
البدايه تكلمنا عن قصه هذا الشركه
ليش تاسست كيف تاسست من ازمه التواصل بين
القطاع الخاص والقطاع العام همم وبعدين
تكلمنا على وش ابرز التحديات اللي تواجه
القطاع الخاص في المرحله الماضيه المرحله
اللي كان فيها الرسوم الغرامات التشريعات
المتسارعه وهمم عدم اشتراك القطاع الخاص
في القرار همم وبعد دخلنا على ملامح
المرحله الماضيه بشكل عام همم قطاع
المطاعم تحديدا لان هو اول تجاربهم او اول
منتجاتهم همم اللي هي جمعيه قوه كيف ساهمت
في تخفيف تحديات هذا القطاع ايش اللي لسه
لازال تحدي في هذا القطاع همم وايش الحلول
المتوقعه والمنتظره اتكلموا على نماذج
اللي عملهم مع جهات حكوميه تكلموا عن قصه
همم
قطاع الصناعه وكيف همم
اشتغلت مع قطاع الصناعي
وكانوا يعني جزء من عملهم لقاء تاريخي مع
ولي عهد نتجت عنه قرارات مهمه همم من
اهمها فصل همم وزاره همم للصناعه بشكل
مستقل وتعيين وزير نائب وزير لهذه الوزاره
فحكونا همم او ابو سلطان الحكام عن كواليس
هذا الاجتماع
والاثار المترتبه عليه وبعدين تكلمني على
القطاع الخاص اليوم قياداته هم اللي
يقودون قطاع الحكومي هذه من ملامح المرحله
الماضيه فهل من وجهه نظر ضيف لا يراها
ايجابيه ولا سلبيه ايش المشاكل اللي يراها
الضيف في هذا ال- ال- المشهد اتكلمنا على
صندوق الصلاه عامه ضيفنا يرى ان الصندوق
ينافس القطاع الخاص وشرح الاسباب ايضا عن
هذه النقطه وبعدين ختمنا الحوار باننا
سالنا سؤال اذا نبغى القطاع الخاص يقود
النمو الاقتصادي مش اكبر ثلاث تحديات
تمنعه من هذا الدور وكانت هذه هي همم
خاتمه الحلقه
فتركم على الحوار حياك الله سلطان شرفتونا
ونورتنا الله يحييك ويطول في عمرك سعيد
جدا جدا باللقاء انا الاسعد والله ابو
سلطان وايش اخر شيء صته
ههه
والله عمرك يعني
خليه يقول لك هذه هوايه وما زالت الهوايه
يعني في القلب ولكن
يعني من زمان
لكن كان عندي شغف وما نزل تحبها جدا سواء
في المملكه في افريقيا في امريكا
ذكر
على المشاريع الحين قائمه في تقريبا
98 لا والله 89 88
كنا نطلع في المناطق اللي حوالين العلا
وتيمه
من حظي اني كنت اشوفها ذكريات واشوف
هالحين شفت اشوف الفرق المنطقه جميله
والصيد فيها جميل بس مش اخر شيء اخذته
هل هو بري ولا بحري
مازال
[موسيقى]
الصيد البحر ما زال شرف قائم حقيقه تجربه
كلها همم
قصدي كيف نمت هوايه وانت ما عندك معها
والله طال عمرك يمكن حبي للطبيعه هذا واحد
همم
البحر او كان البر امبارح
[موسيقى]
يعني سبحان الله انا بالنسبه لي صيد البحر
عجزت عجزت اعلى
البوت واقف في الموجه يلعب فيه هذه الخيال
ثانيا
يا اخي طبيعتي انا احب النتائج الواضحه
انت ممكن ما تصيد ممكن تصيدها سريعه
اكسر هذا الروتين تماما
الهدوم طبعا
بالعكس
بكون معك لا عليك تغسل وابدا ادخل هالعاده
باذن الله احنا ابو سلطان سعداء انه نكسبك
اليوم ضيف معنا همم من زاويه تركيزك
واختصاصك في العلاقه بين القطاع الحكومي
وقطاع الخاص
وهذا نموذج بالنسبه لي جديد وغريب نسولف
عنا بس بعد ما تحكي له اصلا وايش دخلك في
القطاع وكيف ولدت جميل طبعا
طال عمرك اول شي انا نشات
في في عائله رواد عامر
[موسيقى]
عرفني على القطاع امي اسميها منيره
العظيمه
امي رائده في التعليم الاهلي من بداياته
من يمكن اكثر من 30 40 سنه
دار السلام دار السلام
3000 طالب في دار السلام
الجانب الثاني الوالد الوالد
ما بين الصناعه الزراعه القطاع الطبي
تشغيل وصيانه انشطه مختلفه
ثقافه الاعمال التحديات نشات عليها
في بعد الثانويه
ما تحتاج تعليم ادخل في العمل تعلم وبدا
يتفعل 91
همم اشتغلت
وقدرت على قطاعات مختلفه فهمت تحدي في
الصناعه وكيف نعمل تشغيل والصيانه واداره
العماله الكبيره التنظيمات تشريعات همم
وبعدين طبعا كملت البكالوريوس التسويق
وماجستير محاسبه فالحق نفسي همم
وصلت عمرك صار عندي تجربه فيك زي اي رجل
اعمال اخر او رائد اعمال الاحتكاك اللي مع
الحكومه واعرف الصعوبات طبعا لا حب انا
اتكلم على ما قبل الرؤيه احنا نعيش في
عالم مختلف الان
فكان في تحديات تعلمت كيف انه نعمل في ظل
تلك الظروف
الخاصه على المشاريك همم واللي يقود
الاقتصاد زي ما تعرفه القطاع الوقت
[موسيقى]
يعني اذا ما كان ينظر له اه بشكل عادي
يعني
محايد كان ينظر له نظره سلبيه جدا
القطاع الخاص يعني منها ان القطاع ال ال
تاجر
حرامي اااه
ياخذون قصه فرديه ويعممونها بشكل خلي في
انطباع عند الناس انه كل التجار كده
كلنا اخواننا عيالنا كلنا قيادات اليوم
بدينا نقول الاقتصاد كلنا اتجار
وفي القطاع الخاص خلينا نسميها
فكانت نظره مره سلبيه في الوقت التعامل
معنا كان همم غير مرهفي
ايلين طعم عمرك
ولد عمي مشعل بن خالد ولا فضل عظيم علي
كانوا مواصلين المرحله انهم
وصلوا في 15 سنه بنوا 15 فرع
همم بسووا اعاده هيكله كفرات الشركه
ومقبلين على تطور يبغون يتوسعون الاقتصاد
كم مره ممتاز طيبون يفتحون 75 فرع اخر بس
في ثلاث سنوات تخيل 15 سنه 75 ثلاث سنوات
8 وصلنا الى 2010 كان هذا الهدف طبعا عشان
نكون جاهزين
صحيح ثلاث سنوات الجايه تكون تفتحون 75
كان التحدي سوينا كل
الدول
شفنا الموردين شوف كل
الاشياء
التحدي الاول
نحتاج نوظف 1500 موظف في ثلاث سنوات
واغلبهم سعوديين وفريق الوقت كان تحدي
توظيف في السعوديه
تقعد سنه ونصف على اساس
المخططات الين تفتح محل
فعشان تفتح 75 في ثلاث سنوات ما كان ينفع
لها سنه ونصف
فاشتغلت على الملفين هذه التحديات التي
تعيق تحقيق 75 فرح في ثلاث سنوات
فاشتغلت على الملفين
اداره الموارد البشريه
سعوده الكلام هذا الوقت غازي القصيبي الله
يرحمه
[موسيقى]
حقيقه كان في نجاح
يعني فوق التوقعات اقدر اقول ولكن اللي
قادر الجانب الاخر
بدايه عمرك نروح للقطاع العام
ونقنعهم ليش مهم يساعدونا في هذا التوسع
اذا صار التوسع كم سعودي بالموظف كم واحد
يستاجرون فكم اللي بيستفيدون في التطوير
العقاري المقاولين فك حولنا
توسعنا الى مصلحه عامه للجميع ترى هل
توسعه فقط
قدرنا حقيقه نحقق انجازات طاقه التوقعات
ما كنا نتوقع تجاوب
ولكن كنا دائما نصطدم بان انتم شركه واحده
ما نقدر نعطيكم طبعا شيء استثناء تلبس
بشتك تروح
وتاخر استثناء كان هو القاعده
ما هو نظام زي الان
وصلنا الى مرحله انه كان يقولون ما ينفع
انتم نعطيكم الاستثناء هذا
فقلنا اجل نسوي تجمع في الغرفه التجاريه
كنت رئيس اللجنه الضيافه المطعم والمقاهي
في الغرفه التجاريه غرفه الرياض
كمجموعه
فقدرنا اننا نتخطى بعض التحديات
الوزاره
الموارد البشريه تجاره كانت هذه الرئيسيه
في ذاك الوقت اللي تاثر مباشره على
المساجد
اشتغل كالجنه نروح القطاعات نحكي معاهم
نحاول انه نحسن الاجراءات فاهم
الاعتماد المخططات مثلا عشان
ترسل المخطط وترسله للامانه
ويعطوني الكره
من تروح بعد ما تبني طبعا فيها مراحل
بعدين تروح لشركه الكهرباء وتحصل على
كهرباء طويله بعدين المياه بعدين ترجع
للامانه تاخذ
الدفاع المدني
ماساه طبعا حقيقه اليوم افضل ما زالت يعني
ما زال في تحدي ولكن مقارنه باول كنا
نتكلم في سنه ونص الحين نتكلم في 8 شهور
تسع شهور
كدوره راس مال الالم ااه خصوصا يتكلم على
المتجر الصغير ولا ما يقدر يدفع ايجار
ثمانيه شهور ويجيب عماله ولقيت هالفتره
كلها
اللي صارت عمرك
وصلنا لان احيانا نطلب شيء مهم ومنطقي
ولكن كان دائما يقولوا ان انتم تمثلون
الرياضه
توقعنا في مشكله ثانيه
غير انه كان في عندنا تحديات داخل الغرفه
ما كانت بالمرونه اللي تحتاج تتحرك بسرعه
تدخل قرارات الخطابات تطلب مواعيد
جاء وقتها طبعا الكلام هذا الحين صار له
شغلي فيه مقداد تقريبا تسعه سنوات خلصنا
بدانا نطمح الى انه نحسن في بعض التشريعات
صار عندنا اهداف ابعد بس لحظه
هذا الغريب
الاجراءات الصعبه بس لما اقترحوا القيادات
مكه مكه
الكهرباء
نعطيهم خطتنا ل 12 شهر الجايه وين بنفتح
فيه وبدون يمددون ويجهزون الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
اللي صارت عمرك
خلصنا
اشتغلنا على حتى تطويرات اخرى صارت في
الشركه
وصلنا عمرك في عام
اخر 16
انا كان المفروض مع مشعل اشتغل سنه بس
نرتب الانظمه وبعدين بس اخترت سنوات
في
قرارات كثيره همم
تعديل كثير صاير في انظمه الدوله في
الرسوم الى اخره
طبعا انا بعثتها القطع ما عاد ادري عنه
ثاني
[موسيقى]
يعني اخوي حقيقه ابراهيم الجماز والافاضه
العظيمه
جاني وقال لي احنا اتفقنا وغرنا التجاريه
ان نسوي جمعيه اهليه لانه وقتها بحثنا على
افضل
التشكيل القانوني اللي يساعد القطاع انه
يتكلم مع القطاع العام يمثل المملكه يمثل
كل
القطاع الضيافه من نفوت ترك كلين المطعم
الراقي التجاريه وبعد شغلات اللجنه
الوطنيه
باجي لك على الغرفه التجاريه شو الفرق
اللي
قدرنا نسويه في في مكاتفه همم لانه في فرق
كبير تماما بين عملنا وعمل الغرفه
اللي صارت عمرك
قال ابراهيم خلينا نحنا اتفقنا على نسوي
جمعيه انت اليوم محايد ما اتمثل علامه
تجاريه ولا شركه
واشتغلنا سوا في الغرفه التجاريه
وشفنا يعني كيف النتائج كانت ايجابيه
اعتذرت منه
واللي يعرف ابراهيم يعرف شلون اسرارها
عالي
اجتمعنا مره ثانيه واصرنا نسويها للتحديات
تصير في القطاع
وافقت وطلع ابو دليل يعني بشتغل معك سته
اشهر بس الجمعيه نجمع القطاع وبعد ذلك
الجمعيه تقوم بنفسها قالت توكل على الله
من هنا بدات تجربه مكاتفه بدينا نتعلم وش
الاشياء اللي لازم نسويها عشان
نجمع صوت القطط
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل
[موسيقى]
على طاري مكاتفه خليني اعطيني نبذه عنها
عباره عن ايش تصنع فيه هي شركه استشارات
هي شركه
هي عباره عن منصه حقيقيه
تجمع قطاع العام والقطاع الخاص
لانه يعملون سويا لتحسين التشريعات
استراتيجيات
تنظيم صوره القطاع الخاص من هذه المشكله
حقيقه الاساسيه
قبل الرؤيه كان القطاع الخاص ااا يعمل ضل
ضمن الغضروف اللي في ذاك الوقت كل شركه
تعمل لحالها بسببك
اللي يقدر يوصل الاموره الصغير الله يعينه
صارت تحول
تحول فعلا تحول وطني تحولنا من شيء الى
شيء ولكن تحول وطني صار على مستوى الحكومه
وانقطاع الخاص استمر كما هو همم مفرق
مالهم راي واحد
وكان يعتقدون انه فكره البشنه
حتى الحين صرنا نشوف الوزاره
[موسيقى]
القطاع العام تنظم صار عنده توجه صار عنده
رؤيه واهداف وبرامج يعمل
بضمنها تنجح بعضها تفشل بعضها يتحسنونها
ولكن عندهم طريق عندهم لغه صارت حقيقتهم
صار كل الوزارات تتكلم لغه 20 30
غير انه عنده مسدسات عنده يعني وقت محدد
انه يحققه المستهدفات ففي تسارع عالي جدا
في برامج في التشريعات في التنظيمات
القطاع الخاص
وفي محفزات تعرف عن الرسوم
فزادت الفجوه بين الاثنين
وحقيقه المسؤوليه تقع على الطرفين القطاع
العام والقطاع الخاص
القطاع العام
[موسيقى]
صار يشتغلون عندهم مسدسات واضحه بزمن محدد
احترافيه عاليه
وبدو يطورون برامج
في القطاع الخاص انهم يشركونهم
واجهتهم عده مشاكل المشكله الاولى اللي
كانوا القطاع الخاص متعود انه يمثل نفسه
شركه مثل نفسها مو مثل القطاع فكان يجون
الاجتماعات
ويعبرون عن رايهم كامنشاه في هذا النظام
وليس
هذا المشكله الاولى المشكله الثانيه
القطاع الخاص عند اليه انه يختاروا
ممثليننا كانت متروكه الى اجتهادات كثيره
فاللي يجون ليه تكون بالقضاء العام اذا
طلب رايهم همم
ما كانت حقيقه عندهم المهارات المطلوبه
لاعطاء الراي الفني فان والله هذا التشريع
ممكن يسبب تحديات التشريح هذا ممكن نحسن
فيه هنا ما كانت موجوده
اضافه لان القطاع الخاص اللي يجون يشتركون
كانوا كلهم متبرعين بوقتهم فكان يجتهد
يقدم يعني بنستثمار في وقته على قدر محدد
الفضه لان كل اذا زاد الموضوع كبر ما يقدر
عندها شغاله
ايش اللي صار في القطاع العام
صار عندهم صبر
فبدا يمشون بدون التواصل حقيقي مع القطاع
الخاص صار في تواصل شكلي
بدون يسوون ورشه عمل تعالوا هذا النظام شو
رايكم تخيل يعرض عليك استراتيجيه ولا يعرض
عليك مشروع مطلوب منك خلال اربع ساعات انك
تعطي راي فكانت اراء يعني هامشيه حقيقه
وكانت حتى تدار تدار بطريقه ان ال ال
النتائج ورشه العمل تصب في التوجه المرسوم
اساسا يعني خلينا نقول الاجند الاساسيه بس
عشان نقول احنا جئت
طبعا هذه الوزارات ال- ال-
احترافيتها عاليه شويه في وزارات يعني
استشاري وهو اللي قابل القطاع الخاص
والمقابله تكون من واحد يعني مبتدئ
فتكون التجربه يعني تخلط هذه اللي خلص
القطاع الخاص حتى
يفقد المصداقيه في العمل مع القطاع العام
انه مخصص لكم وقت ونجلس معكم ونعطيكم
ملاحظاتنا ولكن ما نشوف ولا شيء منها على
النتيجه النهائيه
فصارتك اكبر القطاع الخاص
عاليه من القطاع
والقطاع الخاص يشوف انه ما في مستقيم في
المشاركه
فالاثنين بعض تمام
بوجود القنوات
[موسيقى]
رحنا طعم عمرك جلسنا مع قيادات القطاع 11
على مستوى المملكه
وهذا صار جزء من منهجيه الان
نروح لكل واحد نقول ليش تقطع المطاعم هذه
اول تجربه لنا فيهم
ليه في مصلحه
وانا نحدد وشنا طالبنا ونحكي مع القطاع
العام بصوت واحد طبعا اغلبهم اللي ما يبغى
يدخل في الموضوع عند شغله واللي يقول انا
جرب تسعه عشر سنوات وما هي فائده
بدينا قلنا على اساس الان عندنا الرؤيه
رؤيا محدده الاهداف
فبدينا نربط القطاع بمستهدفات الرؤيا كم
بالموظف الان احنا كمان نوضح
المراه كم بنسوي في المحتوى المحلي
بيانات كامله وبدينا
مقابل المسؤولين ونقول لهم مجموعه
هذه اللي تحولت الى جمعيه
هذه هذا وضعنا اليوم كيف اختارته الاعضاء
اذا انتم عندكم مشكله
يعني
كلنا عيال قريه
في القطاع معروف مين القيادات المحترفه
سمعتها ممتازه
لهم نشاطات معروفه عنهم
[موسيقى]
هذا اول شيء نقول اختيارهم
هذول نروح نقابلهم
احيانا في المقابله
بعد ما نقابل شخص معين ونتعرف طبعا اكثر
على شخصيته استبعد
ليش
يهمنا
الشخص اللي يكون يمثل الجمعيه انه يقدم
المصلحه العامه المسرح الخاصه واحد
عند رؤيه يشوف التنظيم كيف باثر
ثلاثه بعمرك يتكلم
[موسيقى]
عندنا مشكله انت بتروح تبغات ثياب المسؤول
ولا مسؤولين تبغى تقنعه فاذا ما تعرف تطرح
فكرتك بشكل جيد ما راح يقتل على المسؤول
اربعه عمرك لازم يكون عنده فكر انه يستخدم
من فريق لانه اذا رحنا
انا افهم شيء موضوع معين انا بتكلم عنا
فما ينفع نروح واحنا متفقين كيف نحكي وكيف
نطرح موضوعنا ويصير فيه
كل واحد يدخل ويطرح موضوع مختلف او احيانا
يقول يقابل وزير فيقول فرصه ثانيه
يعني في قبول عالي مع بعض المسؤولين
الين طال عمرك
قابلنا معالي محمد تويجري كان وزير
الاقتصاد
عرضنا عليه 45 دقيقه
[موسيقى]
مريتوا عليها
قال انا بعطيكم
التشريعات اللي تبون تشتغل عليها او اذا
تبغى تشتري الجديده نشتغل عليها بعطيكم
محفزات وبعطيكم ظهور في الرؤيه
في المقابل انتم شو تسوون طلبنا المعالي
30 يوم نرجع له اجتمعنا
اتفقنا على برنامج توظيف 50 الف شاب وشابه
واحد
تدريب 70000 حضرتك
[موسيقى]
كل سنه عشره الاف لمده خمس سنوات
21,000 وبعدين تحول الى برنامج عند
الموارد البشريه برنامج عظيم اسم البرنامج
توطين صرنا جزء من البرنامج يعني البرنامج
في وزاره الصحه وزاره البلديه وزاره
السياحه وقوت
تخيل في المجلس الوزراء
يعني حتى خلاص خمس سنوات ثانيه
[موسيقى]
ابو سلطان عشان يعني نرجع نذكر بالهدف من
الموضوع اللي هو الشراكه بقطاع الخاص
والقطاع العام اليوم
الجمعيه هذه تاسست وسوت هذا الاثر
ابغى افهم حاجتين الحاجه الاولى مين قاعد
تحمل كلها التكاليف انتم انتم مجاهد
والشغل الثانيه وايش الفرق ليش انتم
بتقدروا تقنعونهم يغيرون قرارات والاخذ
امثله على القرارات
عمرك اول شيء كل عملنا يمول القطعه الخاصه
هل اول شيء مين اللي هم الشركات
متساويه
الشركات الكبيره تدفع اكثر شركات صغيره
الشركات الصغيره
بدون مقابل
امرك عشان تعرف انه ال ال
القائد اللي عند الرؤيه كون عند استعدادا
يدفع لان يشوف
الرؤيه انا ممكن اشوف الفائده من هذا
التجمع
ويعرف انه هو بيخطي بيدفع فلوس مو بس له
الشركات الصغيره بيغطي تكاليفهام لهم
هذا واحد اللي فرق طال عمرك
اليوم في في مكاتب
صار اول شيء احنا صرنا
اكثر
[موسيقى]
نحاول نجمعهم الاثنين احيانا نختلف مع
القطاع الخاص اذا شفنا بعض المطالب يعني
ما هي منطقيه والعكس
اول شيء منهجياتنا في شلون نرسل التحديات
بعطيك مثال على التعليم مثلا
قطاع التعليم كان يمرون تحديات كبيره ما
زالوا حقيقتها انا اعتقد قراءه تعليم
محتاجه لنظرها همم يعني
لتصحيحه خصوصا ثاني من الاهلي اااه يمرون
يعني تحديات خصوصا اذا طلعت من المدن
الكبيره تحديات تزيد تعمرك اجتماعنا وهذه
الجزء المنهجيه همم ما نعتمد على
الاستبيانات اول مرحله ما نستخدمها بس اول
مرحله المقابله الشخصيه
نجلس في عمرك مع كل صاحب منشاه نسمع منه
مباشره مش تحدياتك كيف وشلون ليش ليش نعرف
بالضبط وين قدر التحدي وين المشكله موجوده
فيه
التعليم طال عمرك اجتماعنا مع 107 مدرسه
على مستوى المملكه
الكبيره فقط
[موسيقى]
الصغيره فقط حتى في المناطق النهائيه اللي
فيها مدارس نسمع منهم
في نهايه المطاف احيانا الموضوع هذا ياخد
من الشهرين حسب حجم القطاع الى ثلاثه شهور
نطلع في نهايه المطاف
رصدنا التحديات القطاع وليس تحديات
الشركات والمنشات فيطلع عندنا
قائمه واضحه بالتحديات ننظفها في بعضها
حقيقه الهامشيه همم وبعضها شيء شخص له
الشركه تحديدا لحالها
قبلت عمرك ما نقول هذه التحديات اللي
انقطاع ما رضي يشتغل عليها نروح القطاع
العام
الجماعه عندنا انقطع الفلاني تعليم في
الحاله هذه مش اولوياتكم وبعدين موفقه
وزاره التعليم في الحاله هذه يا برنامج
جوده الحياه يا برنامج تحول وطني يا وزاره
الاقتصاد وش نظرتكم هذا القطاع الى وزاره
الماليه مش البرامج الدعم اللي عندكم
بعدين
صار الان عندنا في القطاع الخاص والعام
مقدم عمرك مقترح للقطار نقول لهم بناء على
هذه المعلومات
ونحدد الاولويات هذه بنانا على ثلاثه
اشياء الاول وش الاشياء لو حليناها تاثر
على نمو القطاع
التكاليف الاعمال
وتسهل الاعمال وهذي كلها مستهدفات الرؤيه
كده وافقوا قالوا نعم هذه التحديات اشتغل
عليها ننتقل المرحله اللي بعدها اللي احنا
نسميها استراتيجيه كسب التاييد
وهذه نقطه مره مهمه حديثه يعني اذا بقول
في حاجتين مهمه بسطه التحديات كيف نسويها
واستراتيجيه كشف التاييد
نرسمين اصحاب المصلحه اللي يهمهم قطار
مثلا في التعليم زي ما ذكرت لك لازم وزير
التعليم يعرف وزير الماليه لازم نزورها
نشرح لها برنامج الروح ونشرح لهم اول شيء
حددنا من اصحاب المصلحه
ثاني شيء نشتغل طعامك على وش صاير في
العالم في هذا التحدي
ودائما نروح البيت وانت ناخذ اربع دول
منها فهذا التحدي العالم ايش قاعد يسوي
الثالثه عمرك احنا الان قابلنا الشركات
خلال مقابلاتنا الشركات
نعرف مين الاشخاص اللي فاهمين في القطاع
اللي قلت والله انا ابغى احد فاهم في
التشغيل نعرف في عندنا الخمسه
التوطين وهكذا
فلما نيجي على التحدي من مجموعه تحدي في
التوكيل مين يعني الاكس بوكس اللي عندهم
القدره على تطوير حلول والله عندنا ال 65
يجيبهم كلهم
تحميل
اللي صار عندنا
تحدي واضح ودائما يقولون 50% من الحل انك
تحدد المشكله بشكل جيد ف 50% جبناها
العالم مش قادر يسوي
الفاهمين في القطاع طوروا مقترح شلون
نحلها الان نروح القطاع العام نروح القطار
العام وتسوي اربع حاجات غير اللي ذكرت
الثلاث اول شيء نحكي مع المسؤول
انه ترى قطاعنا عباره عن واحد اثنين ثلاثه
اهميه الاقتصاديه اهميه الاجتماعيه اثرها
على الفرد اثرها على الرؤيه وما نفترض
الوزير والقائد يعرف تفاصيل مو كلهم على
نفس فهمهم لقطاعات معينه
هذا اول شيء سويه ثاني شيء يصير
مشكله وهذا العالم شو يسوي وهذا الحل من
القطاع
بدون مبالغه اقدر اقول لك يعني ما اذكر
انه صار في اعتراض على طرح من الطرح اللي
سواها القطاع طبعا نقطه مره مهمه
نقدم ما نطور حدود
العلاقه بين الاطراف
اللي يصير على طول الوزراء طبعا يحولونها
لجهات المختصه لدراستها والرفع اراهم فيها
احنا ما نوقف هنا
يا سلام
ترى هذا التحدي ترى هذا اللي صاير في
العالم وترى هذا القطاع تم نبدا ندخل معهم
في تطوير الحلول في عنده مستهدفات احنا
عرفناها ولكن في تشريعات في تنظيمات في
شيء عندهم وفي شيء عندهم عشان كذا ارجع
نقطه نحددنا منه اصحاب المصلحه
وزاره معينه يقول لك هذه عند الوزاره
الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
وهنا مع الوزاره الاولى نقنعهم من حنا
وسوينا وانه ليش لازم تساعدونا في حل هذا
الموضوع حتى بدينا يعني نجرب وجهه النظر
بين الجهات المختلفه في القطار العام صار
يشوفوا نفس الصوره انا ليش اذا حليتها مش
بيصير وهذا اذا حلو شو بصير وبعدين نحقق
[موسيقى]
في سؤال
الثانيه خلينا ناخذ امثله مختصره ومتعدده
عشان الناس الشعب
[موسيقى]
قطاع التجزئه
كان في نظام
يمنع المتاجر انها تفتح بعد الساعه 12:00
ويمنع المطاعم انها تفتح بعد الساعه 2:00
العمل بال 24 ساعه ما هو موجود السعوديه
ليه مسببات مختلفه تاريخيه
وجدنا القطاع الخاص
ما اقدر افتح 24 ساعه وهذه فتره همم حسب
تجربتهم وعلمهم انها فيها ايراد جيد همم
الى اخرى
رحنا طعم عمرك سوينا نفس
الترتيب حقنا دراساتنا حقنا جميعنا
الحقائق
رحله عمري وقتها كان معالي القصبي
[موسيقى]
كل الجهات ذات العلاقه ويجتمعون
كان وقتها
الموضوع فعلا بكره الساعه 10:00 الصباح
داخليه الاقتصاد البلديه تجاره كلهم على
طاوله واحده
نشوف
الفرق في
الوزراء في نظرتهم
لاول مره بدينا نشوف
الحنا نجلس على طاوله واحده
او او ينظر لنا على من الشرك
قولي لنا نفس درجه الصوت
النمو القطاع الحكومي صوتها اعلى من سوره
القطاع الخاص او ما في ثقافه في صوت
القطاع الخاص ارجع واقول لان انا محايدين
سوينا الهمر حقنا سوينا المطلوب مننا صار
دورنا مقنع
همم جلسنا تناقشنا اختلفنا
اهلين وصلنا الى اتفاق كيف نغير
الوضع الحالي
لمجلس الوزراء وتم اعتماد النظام الجديد
وطلع نظام 24 ساعه في اخر احصائيه
36000 منشاه استفادت من ترخيص 24 ساعه
بعدها
دراسه على اساس الاثر حتى التغيير
المتوسط 10%
زادت الرادات
تخيل نمو الاقتصادي زاد 10 للقطاع الرئتين
اثنين 10 %
تلقائيا تترجم الى وظائف
تترجم تلقائيا الى زياده مشتريات محتوى
محلي وهكذا وهكذا ورسوم للقضاء العام هذا
واحد
طبعا اشتغلنا طعام رك على مؤخرا على
النطاقات المطوره
ساره الوزاره قريبه جدا من القطاع
وتحدياته يعرف من القطاع اللي يستحمل
يتزاد عليه همم نسب توطين وش ال القطاع
اللي همم نسب التوطين كما هي صار في تقارب
طيب امثله همم اليوم همم اليوم في همم
يعني قاعدين نعيش تجربه انا اعتقد انها
باول تجربه في تاريخ تشريعات
وصلنا حقيقه
لدرجه من التفاهم والمستقيم
والاحترافيه مع وزاره البلديه والقرويه في
اعمال كثيره
انا صار في ثقه لدرجه الوزير
التشريعات كثيره وزاره البلديه حيتا يعني
بتغيرت الان اللي يشوفها صارت جيده ما بعد
شاف اللي بصير بكلها اثر عظيم حقيقيه
تموينات في السعوديه
كانوا ولكن من الخضره ان ترى اليوم عبد
الرحمن القطاع التجاري صار فيه خبرات صار
عنده تجارب ودرجه من احترافيه عاليه جدا
انه يقدر فعلا يعطي رايي
على مستوى
وكلنا وقعنا كجمعيه مطاعم جمعيه تموينات
ماء وزاره البلديه احنا طبعا كلها جمعيات
وقعنا مع الوزاره على اننا نشتغل على
تطوير مقترح لمعايير البناء والتشغيل
للمطاعم والمقاهي ومعايير بينا وتشغيل
للتموينات
اليوم
كل قطاعين هذه يعانون معاناه يعني كبيره
من عدم وضوح النظام وبالتالي الغرامات
غرامات يعني حقيقه اتعبت الصغار قبل
الكبار الكبير يعني عنده شركه كبيره ويقدر
يستحمل العشره الاف وال 20,000 لكن
الطريقه المشكله
يعني كتاب قانون صعب احيانا تفهمها
هو مو فاهم شو المطلوب منه فما يقدر يلتزم
فمع الوزير قال نبغى نطور من معاييرنا
فاعطانا الثقه اللي صارت عمرك القطاع
اجتمع وسوينا التالي
اول شيء سوينا طبعا هذا كل اللي بقوله
ممول من
القطاع الخاص بتحمل مسؤوليه جيب لنا شركه
عالميه متخصصه في
كتابه المعايير
وسوينا طال عمرك مقارنه نرجع المنهجيه
مقارنه الاولى
بريطانيا اوروبا
استراليا واخذنا المره هذه معنا الامارات
عشان نبغى نقيس
التجربه المحليه الاقليميه لان انا
بحريصين النمام حط معايير دوليه الشركات
الصغيره
بكلفها عشان تلتزم فيها نتاكد انه صاير في
همم الجوار
هذا اول شيء ثاني شيء بعد ما جبنا جميعنا
هل المعايير طعامك اجمعنا في قاعه واحده
68 منشاه طبعا الحين بتكلم فقط عن المطاعم
لان مشروعين مفاصله
من طال عمرك المطاعم الراقيه الفاين داينو
الى وحده عندها كشك
الى اخره كلهم موجودين
وراجعنا المعايير واحد واحد المعيار
المختصين موجودين هالمعيار هذا مناسب
على مستوى يصير في العالم يعني ما نخترع
شيء من عندنا
المعايير طبعا كل خطوه نسويها باشراف
وزاره البلديه والقرويه اذا انحرفنا
رجوعنا اذا احنا ماشي الطريق الصحيح
دعمونا
الخطوه اللي بعدها وهذه مره مهمه
نعمل الان على تطوير دليل اجرائي بحيث انا
كصاحب منشاه صغيره افهم هل الاشتراك كيف
اطبقه عندي
شيء ثاني انا كمفتش كيف افتح المعيار هذا
شيء ثالث
اخذنا المواد الدليل حولنا الى ماده
تدريبيه انا ابغى التزام يرتفع اروح
الاكاديميه او اي اكاديميه الماده
التدريبيه موجوده واتدرب على فهم المعايير
فانت غطبقها تقدر تلتزم فالدرجه الوعي
تزيد والتزام يزيد بالتالي
الثالث الان
بموافقه مقام وزاره البلديه اللي بيسمحون
الى مفتش ثالث
شركات متخصصه في
التدقيق على الجوده لانهم يفتشون على
المنشات عشان يتاكدون من هذه غرامات فبيجي
يقول لك عندك
تحدي في المكان الفلاني وهذه طريقه
حلها عشان تلتزم فهذه نقله لانه يصير
انقطاع يعمل لها هذه ثاني
ثاني
البس قبعه شخص مو مره همم
ويبسط الامور
هل نحتاج الى كل هذا الجهد عشان نحط
معايير واضحه وتطبيقات واضحه يعني صاحب
مطعم يقول ترى كل اللي اتمناه اعطوني نظام
واضح
واعطوني انذار اول قبل الغرامه صحيح هذه
الخطوتين بسيطه هل احتاج جمعيه ومكاتفه
واستشارات ورش عمل مفترض ان هذا اساس عمل
الوزاره انها تعطيني النظام واضح وتعطيني
مهله لتصحيح المخالفه اول مره وتحاسبني
بحسب حجمي ما تقارن راعي البوفيه بيراعي
سلسله مطاعم عملاقه في حجم الغرام لان هذه
تكسرها
تختلف على حجم الاثر حجم مخالفه هذه
الاشياء البسيطه ليش ما تسويها الوزاره
بكل بساطه ليش تحتاج الى كل هذا القصه
الطويله عشان اسوي لها اشياء بسيطه
اليوم في العالم القطاع الخاص يلعب بدور
اساس في تطوير التشري
حتى في الحين مثلا في السعوديه عندنا هيئه
المواصفات والمقاييس الدول الاخرى عندها
الجمعيات هي اللي تسوي المواصلات المقاييس
فالقطاع الخاص هو اللي يقود
تطوير لاسباب كثيره منها
اول شيء القطاع الخاص عند الخبرات عارف
ايش اللي المفروض يصير المفروض
من العالم سواء لمنتجات مستوردها او احنا
نصدرها على الاطلاع كامل وداعم
بالتشريعات القصيره والتنظيمات
الثالث عمرك
اليوم حنتكلم عن رؤيا رؤيا تقول القطاع
الخاص شريك فاللي قاعد يصير الان الوزاره
تقدر تسوي الوزاره اساسا سوت يعني وين كنا
في تنظيمات
البلديه وين حنا اليوم تطور عظيم مازال
فيه خطوات لازم تتسووا وش التطور العظيم
اللي صار لانه يمكن بعد يتفقون معك شو
التطور الي صار
عمرك نظام البلديه عباره عن تعميم ما في
نظام همم وكل امانه لها نظام
فكان الامانه تطلع تعاميم
السقف لازم يصير بالشكل الفلاني والارض
بشكل الثاني وكل يوم في تعميم المواقف
لازم يصير حجمها كذا
ومساحتها الى اخره
النظام المواقع التعليميه لا الحين صار في
نظام صح انه يصير تطبيق يصير فيه اخطاء
صحيح ولكن النظام صار واحد مملكه هذا هذه
نقله حداد اروح ابعد من كده وهذا شيء احنا
تركنا فيه
او اشركنا القطعه الخاص فيه
وزاره البلديه قالت
راجعوا كل
الاشتراطات اللي عليها غرامات
وشوفوا شو الاشتراك اللي مبهم مو مبهم مو
واضح مثلا
الاضاءه غير كافيه هذا كان اشترك موجود
والله
فالقطاع الخاص راجع مع القطاع العام وقال
له ترى يا جماعه نواجه مشكله هنا البنت
هذا مو واضح الحين طبعا هم يستخدم همم
الطريقه الالكترونيه شالوا ها الاشتراطات
والغرامات يعني حتى لو راح المفتش وشاف
اضاءه جديده ما يقدر يعطيك خرامه لانها
راحت
هل وصلنا للحين نبغاه لا وانا يعني بسبب
عملنا مع قطاع البلديه اشوف شو قاعد يصير
من التطورات اللي بتحل مشاكل كبيره اول
ترى كان كل شيء غرامه الان دخلنا في تطور
كبير صار في بعض الاشياء عليها
خطوره على صحه المواطن فما زالت فيها
غرامه ولكن جزاوا الغرامه حسب المدن المدن
الصغيره الغرامه اقل عرفت انه ارادهم اقل
كبيره اكبر وهكذا
احنا ليش رحنا لكل هذا الخطوات اللي كان
ممكن نكتفي بنظام واضح ولكن عندنا طموح
حقيقه ان واحد
صاحب المنشاه الصغيره يصير بالنسبه
للموضوع واضح جدا الى درجه الملل انه شو
المطلوب منه
تصير معاييرها عالميه لان الطموح انها
تبدا بره السعوديه فاذا صار عنده معايير
عاليه في السعوديه واضحه يقدر يسوي النظام
امتياز يقدر يطلعها برا السعوديه ونفس قصه
قوه مع المطاعم وش القطاعات اللي سويته
فيها نفس القصه فيها نفس الاثر لو نمر
عليهم قطاعات
القطاع الصناعه يمكن في قصه جميله
قطاعه التموينات للسوبر ماركت
البقالات
قطاع التجربه فيها
الازياء مجوهرات والتجميل
قطع التطوير العقاري هذا القطاع مره مهم
الان طال عمرك في المراحل الاخيره من
شركه توصيل
المنزل
الشركات القطاع اخر شركات التوصيل الركاب
اللي هم اوبر وكريم وما شابه
الان تعمرك رجعنا نعمل مع الصناعه بعد ما
اطلقوا الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه على تاسيس
جمعيات لكل قطاع من قطاع 12
الي في
الخطه حقيقتهم تعليم العمره
الفنادق السياحه بشكل عام
فيه صارت عمرك
تقريبا وش اللي يحدد هذا القطاع هل هو طلب
جائع حكوميه ولا طلب القطاع الخاص
الاول والاساس هل هو قطاع استراتيجي
للرؤيه ولا لا حلو هذا اول واحد ثانيا
ثانيا اذا جاءنا طلب يعني يجينا طلب من
القطاع العام يقول همم جماعه همم
الطريقه اللي حاصل اليوم ما يفعلها وشافوا
في الجمعيات الاخرى والفعاليه العاليه
فيقولون حلو
ان اول قطاع الخاص يجي ويقول همم حنا ودنا
نوح صوتنا بدل ما كل واحد يشتغل حالا
صورته ثانيه طلب من الحكومه يا طلب اقدار
ثالثا المعيار الثالث
الحكومه او القطاع الخاص اوكي الرؤيه هي
المركز حلو العنصر الاساسي هذه تاثر عليها
نرجع قطاع الصناعه وقصتكم مع اللقاء العهد
طعم عمرك وقتها كان معالي الزامل رئيس
اللجنه الوطنيه الصناعيه
وكان يقود تتحرك الصناعه ومعايا الخير كان
نائب الاجنه
يوم الان الوزير ونائبه
همم عمرك همم
المطاعم اللي جمعتكوت تسوون معنا
بدينا حقيقه نشتغل مع ال مع معانيه
مراجعه مشينا على نفس المنهجيه مره اخرى
وش التحديات قبلنا الشركات لين طلعنا
بالاولويات وبعدين تطورنا وش اللي صاير في
العالم بعدين الحلول
لما بدانا في كسب التاييد
بعد ثاني وزاره
وصل خبر لسيد ولي العهد انه صناعيين همم
تنظموا وصار عندهم مطالب
كان يوم اربعاء كلمني مع الزامل قال جاني
اتصال من الديوان ولي العهد بيقابلنا
طبعا مره جاهزين ولكن
تحضر نفسك
وطبعا جزء من طريقه عملنا انه
اذا ما نقدر نحدد المشكله
وحلها واثرها في كرت فمعناها ما اقدر نحدد
المشكله والحل
فسوينا كروتنا
حددنا من الاشخاص اللي فاهمين في كل شيء
يمكن ترى معالي الخريف في لقاء معك قال
لما همم الشباب سووا شغل مرتب لما رحنا
ولي العهد قدرنا نحقق الشباب
[ضحك]
اللي بتتكلم فيها انت همم
طبعا كل واحد على حسب
رحنا
ولي العهد
طبعا تفاجئنا ان ما معنى وزراء بس
الصناعيين
كان فقط اثنين من المكتبه
ويطول لي في عمره
طبعا جانا
وجلس
اااه مسلم
بعدين اعطيت الكروت
اقراها اقراها اقراها بعدين قال تفطر
جت المفاجاه
احنا رايحين
وكنا نحاول انه لغتنا ما تكون فنيه
كثيره
فنتكلم معه يعني انبسط المعتقد البساطه
كان يطول في عمره على النفس
درجه الفهم مو بالموضوع
كان يحكي في الكهرباء بتفصيل عديم كان
يحكي في توطين بشكل عجيب يحكي في الصناعه
المتقدمه
مدخلات الصناعه
حقيقه يعني
في البدايه انه درجه المعرفه عاديه جدا
الاجمل
في وقتها كان يقول مطلب هذا سليم
وان شاء الله متفقين عليه مثلا فصل وزاره
الصناعه عن وزاره الطاقه
في فائده للمنافسه تقرير تكلفه الاعمال
وهكذا المحتوى المحلي المشتري
في بعضها قال ما في خلاف
بعضها قلب ولكن
ليش لا شرح شرح مفصل
واعطانا الوقت نشرح لنا ليش لا وش تاثير
لو عدلنا هذا الطلب او سويناه واش تاثيره
محليه
في وش نظره العالم للسياسات السعوديه
اجتماعنا اسبوعين كنا نطلع من وزاره
الوزاره الوزاره الوزاره يعني
اتذكر انا معي الجدعان
طلعنا من نادي الساعه 12 في الليل
بالتوفيقين على وش الاشياء المطالب اليوم
محددينها وشيلي ممكن منها وفي اللي ممكن
وانت متى ممكن يصير الى اخره فسار حقيقه
طبعا وبعدين في لقاء الثالثه اعتقد معه
ولي العهد
الخريف صار الوزير وزمن صار نائب وقفنا
كمكاد فعلا معهم لانه على اساس انه صار
في تمثيل في الوزاره
اليوم
مع الوزير قال نبغى نسوي لكن ناويين نسوي
في البدايه نسوي تجمعات لان التواصل بيننا
شوف لاحظ كلهم الاثنين قطعه خاص
للتواصل بيننا وبين القطاع الخاص لا يرتقي
للطموح نحنا نبغى شوكه
يمثلون القطاع يمثلون انفسهم
فبدينا الحين في قطاعات مختلفه بدنها
بالادويه وبعدين بنكمل على القطاعات
القطاع الصناعي
وكذلك قطاع المستلزمات او التجهيزات في
قطاع الاجهزه المنزليه والالكترونيه من
طال عمرك مصننه موزع الى ريتال الى جرير
يعني من سوني وبعدها الرحله ابو سلطان
ودي كده يعني يسوي
زوما اوت او نرجع ورا ونشوف المشهد بشكل
عام اتخيل يمكن لو في اشخاص مقطع خاص
يسمعون سواء المنشات صغيره او كبيره
بيقولوا كلام جميل بس ليش مازلنا نعاني
ليش ما زال في تحديات يمكن
سابقا ما كان مطلوب من القطاع الخاص الا
انه يلعب دور جمباز في الاقتصاد الحكومي
هو اللي شايف اقتصادي بالكامل اليوم لا
مطلوب منه يقود بس في نفس الوقت قاعد من
وجهه نظر القطاع الخاص تفرض عليه انظمه او
تشريعات ورسوم وتكاليف اعمال تصعب عليه
التوسع والنمو
وكل الكلام الحلو اللي يسمعونا في وثائق
الرؤيه نبغى نزيد مساهمه القطاع الخاص 140
الى 65% في الناتج محلي يقول القطاع الخاص
هذه كلها كلام الافعال مختلفه عنا من وجهه
نظرهم ليش في هذا الفهم المختلف طول عمره
طبعا اللي انا قلته الى الان
اييي في تحديات وفي تفاوت
يعني مثلا تجد عمرك
وزاره البلديه بقياده معالي الحكيم وزاره
الموارد البشريه
الراجحي وزاره التجاره جائزه معالي
العصبي القصبي
وزاره الاستثمار
وزارات عمرك
فعلا يعني فاتحه ابوابها انها تبغى تشرق
القطاع الخاص بشكل كبير جدا
في مساحه كبيره ان نروح ونعترض ونطرح
وطعمرك يعني لدرجه انه صار لي فكروا في
تشريع جديد يقولون نبغى القطاع الخاص
يشاركنا اسوا شيء قاعد يصير الان يطورون
تشريع وبعدين يطرح للقطاع الخاص لي ابداء
الراي جاهز خالص
هو نفسه اللي همم يعتمد في النهايه
المشاركه الحقيقيه
من اول ما يفكرون في التشريق
تعالي قطع خاص
الوزارات
سوينا دراسه الوقت مليون
احد المسؤولين قال لي
على اخر الزمن انه نسمح لتشريعات الدوله
تصنع في دهاليز القطاع الخاص
واحد في موضوع اخر في وزاره وزاره اخرى
يعني هذا تعتبر خيانه عظمى انه نعطيه
القطاع الخاص
اليوم على مساحه يعني احنا نبغى القطاع
الخاص
وعنده بالتنظيمات وعندهم اجهزه وعندهم
مجلس همم
الخبره الى اخره
لكن
القطاع الخاص يقدر يضيف يقدر فعلا يجود
غير كده
يعني لو تنظر لها منظر اخر
اذا انا شاركت في تشريع واحد حسيت اني انا
اسمع صوتي صرت جزء من هذا التطور اثنين
التزمت فيه لانه انا قلت انه خلونا نسوي
كذا بدل كفاء الاتصال
فيه ممكن الوزارات على نفس المنهج في بعض
الوزاره ما زالت الى الان ابوابها عاليه
فعلا القطاع الخاص ممكن يلعب دور
ففيه تحدي منها الجانب الجانب الاخر
القطاع الخاص ممكن القطاعات نروح لهم احكي
معهم يا جماعه انتم مهمين رؤيا اتذكر لك
مقابله في مايو 2021 كنت تقول اكبر تحدي
اقناع القطاع الخاص يتعاون معنا
[موسيقى]
مقتنعين لانه فعلا
القطاع العام فعلا تغير نتيجه التجارب
سلبيه
هل القطاع العام تغير انت اليوم شخص محايد
واشتغل مع الطرفين هل القطاع العام فعلا
يبقى يسمع القطاع الخاص ولا بس يبغى يقول
شاورماهم همم
البلديه التجاره الاستثمار
همم تخاف ما يحضرني بعضهم فعلا فعلا
يفتحون الابواب لكن
هذا
ومن الجانب القطاع الخاص وايش الجوانب
القصور اللي لاحظتها اللي تخلي مشاركتهم
ما هي فاعله او طلباتهم ما هي منطقيه نحن
نقول يعني في وجهه نظر انه هو قطاع
الطفيلي معتمد بس على المعونات الحكوميه
ما هو منتج عايش على العماله الرخيصه انت
اليوم واقف في النص الاشياء الحقيقيه في
قطاعات همم
تصورهم حقيقيه
المشاركه القطاع العام تصور
مصلحه خاصه بحته
ما ينظرون يرجع ويقول الى الشراكه
تعودوا من الماضي دائما كانوا يفاوضون
لصالحهم فقط
بعض الناس زي ما قلت لك بيرون الناس
ممكن فعلا يصير مع انه يشرح لهم شوفوا ايش
اللي صار
من ملامح المرحله الماضيه
ما المح مره واضح انه القطاع العام صار
يقوده قاده القطاع الخاص فاغلب الوزارات
اليوم الوزير هو عباره عن قائد شركه في
القطاع الخاص قبل ثلاث اربع سنوات تحس هذا
ايجابي ولا ولا سلبي
اول شيء خلينا نقول هم قيادات عظيمه جايين
من شركات عملاقه عندهم تجربه لي اداره
منظومه كبيره
بعضهم اغلبهم
فهمو دورهم انه دورهم مشرع
ونمثل الان الحكومه
وبعضهم
وقل منهم يرى ان نفهم القطاع الخاص
معين
يفهم هذا القطار هذا ما يجعلني افهم في
القطاع المالي وفي القطاع المقاولات
واعتبر انه انا فاهمهم فبالتالي ما يحتاج
تفسيرهم ولا ما يحتاج صحيح
وثقافه اللي اللي جابوها قياداتها قطاع
الخاص الحكومه في جزء منها ايجابي جدا
ثقافه الانتاجيه ثقافه الكفاءه ثقافه
التنفيذ بشكل عام بس وش الجانب السلبي
اللي جبناه من ثقافه القطاع الخاص للقطاع
الحكومي اليوم
موضوع مثلا الاستدامه الماليه هل بلغنا في
موضوع استقلال الوزارات فصارت حريصه على
رسوم حريصه على كل واحده فتحت مجموعه
شركات عشان تستقل ماليا هل هذه فكر قطع
خاصه يعتبر عمرك همم في رايه في تحديات
التحدي الاول
انه ما في تناغم كافي بين الوزارات على
العقوبات
ومبلغ
فكل جهه تتعامل على انها هي اللي تقدم
عندها العقوبه والغرامه الوحيده فتجد صاحب
المسجد
تجيء غرامه من الجهه الاولى والجهه
الثانيه والجهه الثالثه نهايه اليوم تجيه
غرامات تقضي عليها حقيقه ولكن كل واحد
يشوف من منظوره انا غرامتي 5000 ريال
ولكن شفت عشر جهات تفتش كل واحد 5000 هذه
50,000 50,000 هذا البعض المنشات دخل سته
شهور
[موسيقى]
يعني الثاني يطول في عمرك
القطاع الخاص او القيادات اللي جاءت من
القطاع الخاص
رؤيتهم
للمنظومه
ممتازه
تجلس معاهم يفهمونك تماما يفهمون الرؤيه
ولكن طال عمرك
كلمه تنزل شويه في الوزارات كلمه يتحول
تتحول وزاره من مفهوم رؤيه وشراكه الى
مفهوم حكومي بحث الى احيانا في بعض
الوزاره
ما تجد فعلا القبيل اللي يعطيك او عند
المساحه انه يعطيك الشراكه
في لك تغريده في فبراير 2020 تقول هذه
خارج الموضوع بس له علاقه بقطاع الخاص
عموما واللي قاعد يحصل فيك انت تقول انه
ايييي في الوظائف عاليه المهاره اغلب
المواهب اللي في السعوديه هي من دول ناميه
وحطيت رسمه بيانيه فيها مصر والهند
وباكستان
وكنت بتقول انه
هذا النوع من الوظائف المهاره نحتاج فيها
كفاءات من دول همم متقدمه
اشرح لي وش المشكله انت شايفها في القطاع
الخاص وكيف ممكن معالجتها
ده عمرك كده حنا فعلا نبغى نلتقي الى يعني
مستوى الرؤيه
القطاع الخاص ما زال اييي
يستقطب قيادات من
الدول انا في رايي احنا تقدمنا عليها
لا من حيث التشريع ولا من حيث المعايير من
حيث التوجه
انا اعتقد انه يعني مهم انهم يعني زي ما
نستقبل
[موسيقى]
قيادات مناسبه في كل مكان انه الدول اللي
نجيب منها الخبرات لانهم
الاشخاص هذول اللي بيقول خبراتهم من وين
من من دول هم من النظام تعليمهم مو معقول
انه
يجيني استشاري همم او يجيني قائد من
بيئه ااه اكثر تعقيدا من البيئه اللي انا
فيها او اضعف اقتصاديا من البيئه اللي انا
فيها بيقدم لي استشاره او يقود المنشاتي
يعني
المفروض انها تتوجه المفهوم يختلف شويه
المهاره يعني هل لها تصنيف معين
الوظائف عاليه المهاره طال عمرك يعني بس
خلص عندهم عاليات تقنيه عنده مهاراتهم
عاليه افعاله تعريفها
نفس
السياق التغريدات المثيره في لك تغريده في
الفتره عن او بقراها بالنص لا يوجد منافس
للسعوديه في 2030 لا في العالم العربي ولا
الشرق الاوسط
لكن تغيرت قناتي بعد زياره القاهره مصر
اصبحت منافس حقيقي يتفوقون علينا ويتفوق
عليهم واكبر مميز لنا ولهم العنصر البشري
كنت اردت تكامل مع الامارات ولكن التكامل
مع مصر هو المستقبل والامارات
دوله مصر
عمرك عندها ميزات يعني اذا نحن نظرنا الى
الصناعه البسيطه
ما هي متقدمه
مصر عندها عناصر الموارد البشريه تكلفتها
اقل
حجم السوق كبير جدا
التكلفه الاعمال الاقل كتير
سياحه مصر لو تحسنوا شوي صار
في منافس قوي لنا في السعوديه خصوص
المشارينا مع المشاريع النوعيه
التطور اللي قاعد يصير طبعا الان وضع
الاقتصادي صعب لكن التطور الجاهل يصير
يعني زرت المدينه الاداريه الجديده
زرت مناطق مشاريعهم الخمسه الجيجا بروجيكت
البنيه التحتيه شلون تغيرت ففي شغل قاعد
يصير لكن اذا فعلا حنا نبغى يصير في تكامل
انا اعتقد تكامل اللي بيكون بين السعوديه
وثقلها ومصر وثقلها على مستوى العالم
بيكون جبار خصوصا انه نحن فريق
مصر بوابه
مع الامارات
هل هي تكامل تنافس ولا ما في مقارنه
يعني نحن مكمله تنافس
الرياض واستراتيجيه الرياض وكبه تكون
السياحه اللي بتكون في الساحل الغربي ااا
الاستقطاب الشركات العالميه
مكمله ما زال
السوق الاماراتي يعتمد على السوق السعودي
همم في مصلحه طبعا للتقارب ولكن اعتقد
المصلحه من طرفهم اعلى همم لكنهصر اوكي
القطاع الخاص
ودوره في الرؤيه يذكر صندوق الصلاه العامه
وشركاته
في جدل طويل جدا
القطاع الخاص يقول الصندوق ينافسنا اخر
مقابله لي معالي رميان كان يقول احنا
المكن القطاع الخاص وطلعتنا القطاع الخاص
يعطيني مثال واحد
اعطاني مثال همم انت كيف تشوف دور القطاع
الخاص او دور صندوق صوره العامه مع القطاع
الخاص في مرحله الرؤيه
كذا منظور
في في من سوريا على الاثنين
في خل التفاصيل في مشاريع قبل التفصيل
الاجابه ال ال الاوليه صندوق صلاه العامه
ينافس القطاع الخاص او يمركز القطاع الخاص
نوعيه المخاطره فيها عاليه القطاع الخاص
ما رح يسويها ولكنها اساسيه لان القطاع
العام هو اللي يسويها
في صناعات تعورك جديده تماما القطع
السياحي
يحتاج لابونيا تحديث فمفهوم القطاع في
مشاريع تحتاج مبالغ ضخمه جدا الجيجا
بروجيكت مستحيل القطاع الخاص سوريا بهذا
ما في خلاف عليها
الجانب الثاني
القطاع الخاص
طرحت له فرص وكان في النشره الثانيه من
برنامج التحول الوطني ذكر صراحه لان
القطاع الخاص بالتحديات التطبيق الرؤيه
القطاع الخاص لم يستغل الفرص المطروحه من
الرؤيه ففي مشاريع كان مطلوب من القطاع
الخاص ان يسويها ما سووها فاضطر القطاع
الاصول والاستثمارات السوريه
ولكن
وهذه الوحده من مطالب الصناعيه مثلا ان
المشاريع
الصندوق الاستثمارات ما طبعا هم لهم نظام
مشتريات غير نظام الحكومي النظام الحكومي
في اولويات المحتوى المحلي
واحده مطالبهم كانت الموضوع
فقط
في
اقتصاديات كثيره حوالين المشروع الكبير ما
تمت يعني انا احتاج همم
[موسيقى]
التوطين المحلات
الاستثمارات الصندوق الاستثمارات العامه
عمرك
قبل قبل المقابله بالصدفه الوحده
كان القطاع الخاص
يشتكي من منافسه
صندوق استماره العامه وكالعاده
سمعنا التحدي بدانا نجمع المعلومات
المباشر
الى المنافسه الغير مباشره او ما سمي غير
مباشره يعني مثلا
انا بسوي مشروع
تطوير عقاري كبير
ابيعاني عشان مخططاتي تعتمد
الكهرباء
سعرهم انا ما اقدر اجيبه كان مطور عقاري
اسرع
يعني يتعامل معنا جهاز حكومي وليس قطع خاص
وكان كثير من رجال الاعمال
ما نقول لا ينافس ام رواق بس على الاقل
بنفس المعامله
فيعني الى ابسط الامور
نحنا اليوم
قاعد يشتغل ويطول مشاريع في روشن ويستفيد
من هذه المزايا اللي احنا لاننا حكومه
هو متى يعطي القطاع الخاص
لو انا شركه كبيره
وبسوي مشروع نفس الفكره
هذا التحدي
وهذه وحده من الحاجات اللي مثلا ليش اقول
لك معلوم الان انشا واحده للتواصل مع
القطاع العام القطاع الخاص بس حقيقه ما
بعد عملنا معهم
نسمع عن شركه جديده
لصندوق استماره العامه لصناعه الاجهزه
المنزليه
القطاع الخاص عايش رعب انه استثمر في مصنع
زود خط الانتاج
ولا انتظر لنشوف الشركه هذه شو بتسوي اذا
جاء دخل الاستفارات العامه في الاجهزه
المنزليه يعني
بتسبب يعني التحدي
النظر
القطاع الخاص يقول احنا لا يمكن يكون
عندنا نفس الموارد وال- والوصول للانظمه
والتشريعات اللي قاعد يحضر به فندق
تعتبر مستحيله همم
القطاع العام في المقابله يقول قطاع الخاص
ما هو قاعد يركب الطلب اللي احنا والسرعه
لها محتاجين نسويه شركات اللي تحدد هذه
المعايير وبعدين القوي الله يحييك واللي
ما يقدر ينافس السوق
كيف نقدر نوازن بين هل شغلتين
بمنهجيه مكافحه
حنا ما نقدم مقترح ما نطور تشريح حلول
السؤال هذا انا اخذه منك واروح القطار
الخاص
واجمل الاجابات منهم
رتبها وحددها
وحطها بصيغه احترافيه وانقل الصوره هذه
للقطع لها اذا القطاع العام عنده تحدي هذا
لكن حتى راينا الشخص يعني انا اللي رايي
لا يؤثر على هذا المقطع دورنا في مكاتب
الحياديه نجمع هذا الراي اللي هم يشتكوا
منه لانه اذا فعلا احنا نبغى يمكن قد يكون
التصور اللي عندهم ما هو كامل
جزء من الحل واحيانا كثيره ترى على فكره
نجد ان المشكله همم عدم فهم القطاع الخاص
يعمل استراتيجيه او التشريه مجرد انه
يفهمه تنحب يعني بعطيك همم
مطلقه في يناير سمعنا التطبيق مكاتفه
عندنا مشكله في القطاع الخاص ان تطلع
تشريعات
طبعا المشكله مين عند الشركات الكبيره
عندهم موارد وعندهم موظفين يجيبون الاخبار
مشكلتك اقطع عمرك في الصغير
ومشكلتك تكبر اذا راحت للصغير اللي برا
المدن الكبيره اذا طلعت تشريع جديد
99% من الناس
ينزل يمكن في بعض الجرائد المحليه ولا
ينزل تويتر ولا ينزل في صفحه الوزاره
احب محل هذا بعيد عني تماما
فكره التطبيق لانه وجدنا التحدي تطبيق
مجاني فكره التالي واحد انا صاحب متجر
اجهزه ادخل على التطبيق في مكان
الخاص فيني فقط متجر
واحد اثنين كل الاخبار اللي تاثر على محلي
تطبيق تنزل بشكل مختصر ما بين نص مكتوب او
فيديو همم علشان سهل الشرح
ثلاثه امرك
في مكان تجد فيه وشي التشريعات اللي الان
قاعدين نشتغل عليها تعرف اول شيء شو اللي
جاي لانه في مشكله انا كشركه كبيره اقدر
اعرف وش اللي جاي في التشريع فابدا ارتب
من الحين خططي على اساس انه اذا نزلت
تشريع استفيد منه او اذا نزلها التكلفه
اكون جاهز الصغير
فقط اللي يحتاج المعلومه فاذا عرف ان فيه
تنظيم جديد جديد يصير هو الكبير متساوي
هذا الثاني او الثالث الرابع في يطع عمرك
اليوم عشان يصير فيه تواصل بين القطاع
الوسيله الوحيده الوتساب فتجد فيه القطاع
الواحد يمكن 50 وات
في غرف التواصل الاجتماعي موجوده في
التطبيق يقدروا يدخلون يتبادلون الخبرات
التحديات المشاكل طبعا هذه بتساعدنا
بتساعدنا اول شيء نرصد التحديات لان ما
نبغى نتعدى المرحله اللي احنا فيها اليوم
نبغى نوصل للمرحله انه يصير في عندنا يعني
الاحساس بنبض الشارع وين التحدي
نوصل للمرحله انه حتى اللي في في قريه
يقدر يشوف التشريع ويحط رايه على التشريق
كل بساطه وسلاسه فا الاهم حقيقه وهذا اللي
يعني
يعني ان شاء الله نقدر نوصل خلال سنتين
القادمه
نبغى نتعدى مرحله عندي تحدي الى عندي حلول
او عندي طرح ليش ما نشتغل في
الصناعي الفلانيه ليش ما نسوي شيء الفلاني
نقدر يتحرك
خليني اختم واقول يعني وحده من اهم اهداف
رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 انقطاع القطاع الخاص
يقود النمو الاقتصادي وانقطاع الخاص
المحلي من 40 الى 65% على ما اظن
لو بسالك من واقع خبرتك
ايش اكبر ثلاث اسباب
تعيق تحقيقنا لهذا الهاتف
انقطاع الخاص هو اللي يقود النمر القصادي
هل فعلا القطاع الخاص ما هو مصدق ان فعلا
بيسمح لنا يلعب الدور هذا الى اليوم
القطاع الخاص ما شاف انه شريك حقيقي اعطيك
امثله او مثال واحد
انت فعلا تبغاني اقود القطاع الخاص
ادعمني
اذا انا اخطيت اشرح لي انا كيف اخطيت
طورني
[موسيقى]
لكن مو بتجيني تعاقبني
العقاب ما نختلف ان جزء من تطبيق السياسه
ولكن في شيء يسبق حتى الانذار اكثر من
انذار
فعلا هل نبغى القطاع الخاص يصير شريك
المصداقيه الثقه ما زال يبغى لها شغل بين
الطرفين
ثلاثه عمرك
ويمكن تصب في
المستقيم كذلك
للشراك الشراكه الحقيقيه
ليش ما يسمح للقطاع الخاص ان يصير مستثمر
مع صندوق استثمارات
حتى لو كان استثمارات بسيطه بس يكون
مستثمر ياما يكون مستثمر راس مال يكون
مستثمر في التشغيل بس يكون جزء شريك حقيقي
في لانه اليوم لو تنظر لصندوق استمارات
العامه انا اخذ كمثال طبعا
احترافيه عاليه حتى لو رحنا الشركه
الوطنيه للاسكان احترافيه مذهله حقيقه
شراكتي يمكن هذا نرجع نقطه انه المقاولين
او المقاولين العقاريين يشتغلون مع الشركه
الوطنيه ترفع من معاييرهم فهذه شراكه تاهل
لليوم صغير انه بكره يصير كبير
عمرك
في شركات كثيره
اليوم ليه القطاع العام دائما هو يفكر كل
مبادره عند عنده مشكله هو يسوي المغادره
انا بسوي منصه عشان تواصل انا بسوي لا
القطاع الخاص
اخذ شركات صغيره واضحه القطاع الخاص اليوم
صغير بكره بصير كبير
حتى النظره الي الشراكه في القطاع الخاص
في حلول كثيره يحتاجونها اعطوها القطاع
الخاص
بالتوفيق ابو سلطان في بناء منصه
للشراكه بقطاع العام وقطاع الخاص حتى
يقودها قطاع ان شاء الله اقتصاد في 20 30
او قبل او بعدها بشويه ان شاء الله
شكرا لك شكرا لكم
الكاميرا في تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز
المزيدي وفي التحرير وفي الهندسه الصوتيه
محمد الحسن والاشراف على الانتاج رزان
احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]